من رام الله الكاتب والباحث السياسي ساري
عرابي سيد ساري عرابي مرحبا بك معنا
بالنظر لمحددات التي تحدث عنها اسامه
حمدان القيادي في حماس لاتفاق اطار حول
صفقه وقف اطلاق نار وتبادل
اسرى هل تعتقد بان اثناء
هذه الظروف هي ممكنه هذا هذا النوع من
المحددات بالنظر الى ما قيل عن هذه
الصفقه
يعني لا شك ان الفجوه والمسافه واسعه جدا
ما بين الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وما بين حركه
حماس والفلسطينيين عموما وفصائل المقاومه
عموما ولا شك ان اتفاق الاطار الذي اشار
اليه الاستاذ اسامه حمدان لا يشكل حتى هذه
اللحظه الضمانات الكافيه بالنسبه
للفلسطينيين وبالنسبه لحركه حماس من اجل
وقف العدوان الاسرائيلي على الفلسطينيين
داخل قطاع غزه ورفع الحصار واعاده الاعمار
وما سوى ذلك من مطالب جوهريه الحقيقه لكن
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي نحن ااء صورتين
متقابلتين على هذا الصعيد نحن ااء صوره
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الذي يفتقد في هذه
اللحظه القدره على اتخاذ موقف واضح والذي
يعني يتسم موقفه بقدر كبير جدا وقدر عالي
جدا من الخلافات الداخليه وعدم القدره على
الاتفاق على رؤيه كليه واستراتيجيه حتى
على هذا المستوى المتعلق بصفقه تبادل اسرى
ما بين الفلسطينيين والكيان الاسرائيلي
فكيف بما هو اكثر من ذلك على مستوى انسحاب
ووقف عدوان على الفلسطينيين داخل قطاع غزه
لكن في المق قابل يظهر الفلسطينيون انا
اتحدث تحديدا عن فصائل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه داخل قطاع غزه يظهر
الفلسطينيون قدره على اتخاذ موقف واحد على
التشاور على الظهور بموقف واحد على عدم
ظهور اختلافات او تباينات او تنافر بين
مختلف فصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه ولذلك
يحاول ب نتنياهو ان يلعب هذه اللعبه في
حين انه عاجز عن اتخاذ موقف على مستوى
المؤسسه الاسرائيليه عموما موقف على مستوى
حلفائه وشركائه في المؤسسه الاسرائيليه
اذاء هذا الموضوع يحاول ان يقطع الطريق
على الخلافات الداخليه الموجوده عندهم وان
يلقي الكره في ملعب حركه المقاومه
الاسلاميه حماس وبقيه الفلسطينين ولكنه في
النهايه سيصل الى نقطه هي مفترق طرق يعني
يجب ان يقرر فيها وان اما ان يذهب الى
صفقه اتفاق اطار تبادل للاسرى واما يعني
انه سيواصل الحرب وهو امر لا يمكن يعني
متابعته بنظر كثيرين حتى من داخل
اسرائيل ولذلك لذلك اعتقد ان حركه حماس
وفصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه تدير هذا
الامر بنوع من المناوره الذكيه في الحقيقه
يعني بمعنى في حين ان اتفاق الاطار هذا لا
يلبي لفصائل المقاومه ولا يلبي لحركه حماس
المطالب الاساسيه والجوهريه التي من
الممكن ان يرتكز اليها لضمان وقف العدوان
الاسرائيلي على الفلسطينيين داخل قطاع غزه
ولكن من الواضح تماما ان فصائل المقاومه
وحركه حماس لا تريد ان ترفض هذا الاتفاق
رفضا صريحا ومباشرا بما يوفر لبنم نتنياهو
يعني فرصه قطع الخلاف والسجال الدائر في
المؤسسه الاسرائيليه وفي الاوساط
الاسرائيليه المتعدده ومن ثم يمكن ان نقول
ان نمطا ما من التفاوض بصوره غير مباشره
قد جرى على اتفاق الاطار هذا يعني بمعنى
ان حركه حماس والفصائل الفلسطينيه لن ترفض
هذا الاتفاق الاطار بقدر ما انها سوف تبدي
ملاحظاتها وسوف تبدي تعديلاتها وانا اعتقد
ان هذه قد تكون مناوره جيده على هذا
الصعيد يعني بمعنى لن يكون من طرف
الفلسطينيين الموافقه كامله على اتفاق
الاطار هذا ولكن ايضا لن يكن هناك رفضا
بما يوفر لبنيامين نتنياهو الحقيقه فرصه
الادعاء ان الفلسطينيين هم الذين يعرقلون
فرصه يعني اجراء تفاهم لتبادل الاسرى او
فرصه توفير ارضيه او فرصه معينه لانتهاء
او الخروج من هذه الحرب يعني بمعنى نحن
نتحدث عن استعصاء اسرائيلي اكثر مما نتحدث
عن استعصاء فلسطيني على هذا الصعيد في كل
الاحوال ليس سهلا على بنيامين نتنياهو
وليس سهلا على كل المؤسسه الاسرائيليه ان
تتخذ قرارا بوقف الحرب العدوانيه على
الفلسطينيين داخل قطاع غزه لكن من الواضح
يت تماما ان هناك نقطه حرجه وصل اليها
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على هذا الصعيد في
حين انه غير قادر على اتخاذ القرار الحاسم
فيما يتعلق بمجريات هذه الحرب حتى بتفاصيل
من هذا النوع او اتخاذ قرار فيما هو اكبر
من ذلك بوقف الحرب العدوانيه على
الفلسطينيين داخل قطاع غزه ولكنه مدرك
تماما انه قد بلغ ايضا مرحله حرجه من حيث
تعثر هذه الحرب العدوانيه على الفلسطينيين
داخل قطاع غزه العجز عن انجاز الاهداف
الكليه الكبرى التي اعلنها الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي في بدايه هذه الحرب ظهور
الخلافات واستفحال الخلافات داخل المجتمع
الاسرائيلي صحيح لم تبلغ درجه حاسمه لفرض
قرار ما على بنيامين نتنياهو ولكنها في
الاخر في النتيجه اخذه بالتصاعد يعني بما
يعمق من حاله الاستعصاء الاسرائيلي هذه
شكرا لك من رام الله الكاتب والبحث
السياسي ساري عرابي